we got a new guy a couple months ago not
just a new guy but a first-timer it's
always interesting getting a new guy
because you can sort of see yourself in
them and vicariously experience when you
first got sent in here without actually
needing to experience it for yourself
again
you wouldn't think you would want to
even vicariously do that considering how
surface-level horrible the experience is
but there's always something appealing
about it it's sort of a reminder of how
far you've come I suppose when he first
came in you could see it on his face the
same look every guy has when they enter
into this new world for the first time
it's an awareness of uncertainty paired
with a refusal to accept it fear masked
by bravado the kind of bravado that
needs bravado to prove itself the self
announcing sort which is almost always a
surefire sign that there exists a fear
in the person that the person hasn't
even yet braved confronting it was
carried in the way he walked and talked
he was still hopeful that he could force
his way through the whole thing he was
still hopeful that it wouldn't be what
he knew deep down it would new guys
always do this I did it the first day is
the worst and then the next several
dozens of days after aren't really that
much better
he sort of exists in a weird state of
limbo for a while while you go through
the process of denial not even just
conscious denial but a natural
resistance to your new circumstances the
first weeks and sometimes the first
months are just a transitioning period
where your mind seems to have a lag time
behind reality for a while you are
literally in this new world but all your
senses and expectations are still in the
old and in this you find yourself sort
of searching for something that doesn't
exist anymore fighting against the
nothingness met by your expectations
this is the hardest part coming to terms
with a change and until you've come to
terms with being isolated and confined
from your previous world you definitely
haven't come anywhere close to figuring
out how to be okay with it eventually
though you do and for some you even come
to like it but first for most people
including myself as the initial day
start to flip into weeks and months you
seem to dip for at least some period of
time into hopelessness it seems for some
reason you have to go there first
as if hopelessness is always on the way
between two different states of
hopefulness and it's the only way
through to the other side
I think any time you're confronted with
how little control you have how cruel
everything including yourself can be how
easily everything can be taken away or
flipped on its head and how truly
helpless dissolute and alone you are the
only way to keep hope is to quickly
touch hopelessness first and feel how
bad it hurts it's like a little kid
touching a hot stove over light bulb you
almost don't believe it's that bad or
for some reason you're just curious
about how bad it really is and you have
to touch it to believe it
once you have though you're pretty much
ready to take your hand off as soon as
possible and find some other way to live
that's how it was for me at least some
people do seem to get stuck there though
sadly some people like the additional
pain even after it had been something
like two or three weeks since the new
guy got here he was still antsy every
day all day causing fights acting
strange forcing himself into this and
that even when he was physically doing
nothing you could see him racing around
in his head anxious and guilty of his
procrastination with reality in truth
you're always isolated in yourself in
your own isolated section of the
universe but in here you feel that both
metaphysically and physically and I
think that's why it's so much harder to
confront but equally essential it took
me a couple months to properly get past
it myself eventually though you don't
have a choice you either go mad fighting
your present reality or you face it and
then eventually you wake up and what
once felt completely foreign feels
completely normal and you almost never
even notice everything becomes a
different normal than the normal before
but it feels no less normal that's the
interesting part about normal that it's
essentially always the same no matter
what form it takes as soon as something
becomes normal it feels the same as any
other normal normal is just normal life
can somehow be entirely different and
yet it will likely at some point feel
mostly the same I once read that after
every seven years or so every cell in
the human body has completely
regenerated and the body becomes made
entirely of a different collection of
physical material at which point nothing
that was once you is you anymore and
across seven years your life
circumstances are likely different to if
not
completely different meaning both your
interior physical state and exterior
circumstances are constantly changing
completely and yet you always feel
mostly the same at least in the sense
that you still feel like you it seems as
if all processes of change in life are
sifted through the same colander of self
and the only thing that it's ever
consistent on any level in any
circumstance is that thing inside your
head that continually identifies you
with you despite what's going on around
and through it and that's sort of
ultimately what it all comes down to I
think how will you exist with that
strange central you that observes all
the other dynamic and constantly
changing news if anything is this that
solitude and separation provides the
value and reformative nature of
confinement is at least for me not
necessarily to develop into a different
person but to properly face the strange
painful difficult and almost
inexplicable person you might really be
the person who isn't even really a
person but the thing that lacks a
complete and obvious person but longs
relentlessly for one the truth of what
you might be that you went to great
massive efforts to otherwise avoid and
instead you direct your efforts to learn
how to live with this rather than always
lashing and flailing away from it that's
where the real trouble came from for me
anyway eventually if your strategy is to
flail violently against yourself in an
effort to overtake it you'll end up
going to the end of the world losing
everything you have in love just to
ultimately end up being put here to
confront the same fact that you knew all
along that you always go with you
arguably some level of solitude is
inevitable in any life but perhaps some
level of deeper intentional solitude is
necessary for a good one at least for a
period of time even in a crowd of
thousands of people every person is
ultimately alone inside their head as a
solitary receiver of everything
everything and everyone is experienced
individually skull by skull moment by
moment once for all eternity and so what
does it mean to be a solitaire receiver
of a world of noise if when the noise is
turned down
you can't barely stand it perhaps some
decent amount of solitude grants you the
first step in confronting just how
broken the receiver inherently is
finally letting you hear the static buzz
that's been humming in the background of
everything that you can only directly
notice when nearly everything else turns
down at first this humming drove me
crazy sometimes to the brink of all
hopelessness but then like everything
else you begin to adapt you begin to
better accept it learn how to live with
it and use it properly now that you know
what's been there causing most of the
problems granted this is all just my
experience and I don't wish to portray
it as anything but that nor do I wish to
portray any conclusive awareness as to
how I might turn out and what this all
might equate to when my term is over and
I'm finally released back into the world
I think it probably takes a full
lifetime to ever know what you really
are and what good anything was for you
but if there's any hope and ever being
okay in any version of life despite this
any hope and ever feeling like one has
any level of agency over themselves
while in the chaos of the outside world
I think one must first be able to feel
okay and in control of themselves when
nearly all other factors of distractions
have been subtracted and your freedom
and sense of life has been narrowed all
the way down to your skull sized domain
I know everyone in here doesn't have the
luxury of hope but for those that do I
think it would only be but another crime
to squander it and I was happy to see
that after about three or four months in
the new guy chilled-out stop causing
fights stop acting crazy it's mostly
always the same eventually everyone
figures out how to be okay eventually
you don't have a choice
[Music]